[Musik]
so leute ich hoffe ihr seht mich gut
morgen was die dab willkommen bei einer
ngo freut gibt nach oberhausen ich will
gar nicht eingeladen ich mache mir noch
wer denkt da schon los zuschauer treffen
heute im centro bei c&a let's go
[Musik]
immer betrieben
okay heute
ich würde sagen
[Musik]
nur eine gewisse vergingen wie im flug
eingang und ich gebe ich jetzt mal
schick machen zu sagen wir gehen auf
toilette
[Musik]
wir fragen jetzt nur 31 und das ganz
begegnung durchaus schon heute steht
schon der 1
deswegen ist strikt ab
unser leben
ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt arbeitet
ruhig ab
[Musik]
und wie schön
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich sage also keine aber es hat mich als
wrestler so mehr gefreut kratze mich
etwa so viele leute da ich konnte nicht
lange
irgendwie nie wen die gegen haltern um
die ecke und dann irgendwie noch mal
keinen halt nur in die richtung gucken
wie wird gesagt fand sieben oder acht
leute echt mega kraft gegend wie alles
so alles was mir gesagt wurde ich habe
so viele menschen gesehen einfach so ich
sehe mir nur diese zahl aber dahinter
sind durch eine richtig coole
wundervolle menschen und ich sind mehr
kraft ich war auch dauphine handy
hintergründen einfach drauf das handy
wird angemacht und nicht weil ich da wo
ich mir dass der alpha richtigkeit das
gibt mir das gefühl so einiges richtig
machen des friedens wie das mega
dankeschön tadese wie möglich war dass
alles so gut geklappt hat der ablauf
alles hier hab ich mir gefreut wieder
ich bin mal gespannt wer 14 tage wenn
spiel gewinnt wer gewinnt die 5000 euro
da bin ich gespannt welche klasse welche
stufe dabei sein wird
ja leute mehr will ich gar nicht sagen
ich hoffe dass sie dadurch gefallen und
mehr kraft eingestellt
an alle die da waren es war echt mal
wieder eine unglaubliche erfahrung für
mich und danke ich wünsche euch noch
einen schönen tag vor 3
[Musik]